(fanfare music)
- I did it.
I won.
(dramatic music)
(explosion)
(bell dinging)
(people screaming)
- Is that all you've got?
Losers.
You're gonna have to do better than that.
(zombie growling)
(man screaming)
(bell dinging)
(dramatic music)
(marker squeeking)
(bell dinging)
(dramatic music)
(people grunting)
(bell dinging)
(car banging)
(arrow swooshing)
(man gurgling)
(bell dinging)
- We built your empire.
Engineered those generators.
Constructed those sweet ass rides.
Any tech we salvage, any food we find,
you bully us into handing it over.
(gun clicking)
We have nothing.
Face it, you're assholes.
(gun blasting)
(bell dinging)
(dramatic music)
(marker squeaking)
(bell dinging)
(dramatic music)
- [Toy Bear] I love you.
(explosion)
(bell dinging)
(dramatic music)
- Drop him.
- [Guy] Wait what?
(guy screaming)
(bell dinging)
(upbeat music)
- [Angelica] This is what being
in the mafia was all about.
(trunk squeaking)
(bell dinging)
(chainsaw revving)
(man screaming)
(bell dinging)
(people screaming)
(guitar rift)
(bell dinging)
- [Man] (screaming) my hammy (screaming).
♪ Ah, can I cut you
up, can I fuck you up ♪
♪ I think I'm gonna fuck you up ♪
♪ Gonna cut you up, gonna fuck you up ♪
(bell dinging)
♪ And then I'm gonna fuck you up ♪
♪ Gonna cut you up,
gonna let you have it ♪
(bell dinging)
♪ I'm gonna cut you up ♪
(upbeat music)
(dog growling)
- Shit.
- Oh.
(man crying)
- [Man] No, no, no, no, no.
- God damn.
- Pug mating season.
(bell dinging)
(guy yelling)
- Please stop.
(sad music)
- Nah, man, it's fine.
I got you.
No, no Eli.
Help.
Somebody.
♪ Heart and mind. ♪
- Get to the high school.
- What, man, anything.
- You touch my Magic the Gathering cards,
and I will haunt your ass.
You don't want to fuck
with paranormal Eli.
I'm terrifying as shit.
- Eli.
(bell dinging)
♪ Hold me down ♪
- Eli.
No, no, man wake up.
Wake back up man.
Get up.
♪ Remember the words that we made bold ♪
(bell dinging)
(upbeat music)
(man grunts)
- Oh, shit.
(bell dinging)
(explosion)
(people screaming)
(upbeat music)
(bell dinging)
(people screaming)
- I have to stay under
my mileage for the lease.
(thudding)
- It's dark out.
No one will see if I don't
pick up the dog's poo.
(bell dinging)
(arrows whooshing)
(man grunting)
(bell dinging)
- Here.
(thudding)
(dramatic music)
- Get up.
We know you can't be stabbed.
I saw you, remember?
The whole ax thing.
- Eh, ah, come on.
Why'd you stab me if you
knew I wasn't gonna die?
- Wasn't the sword that
was meant to kill you.
It's what's on it.
Peanut butter.
(man grunting)
(man screaming)
(people gasping)
- Easy, easy boy, easy boy.
Hey Josh.
Fuck you.
(sword slicing)
(finger splatting)
(bell dinging)